One last thing about password hashing. You know, all of this
is, is, is, is good to understand. And most modern computers
hash passwords in just the same way I showed you. Generally
we, you can use SHA-256 that works okay. The problem with most
hashing functions, is that they're designed to be fast. So generally
this is a good thing. You know, if, if you're going to be
using this hashing function, you know, to be verifying your cookies
and what not. Yeah, you want it to be fast, you want to
slow down your web server verifying, you know, cookie data all
the time. But for cases like passwords, when it's much more likely
that somebodies going to be trying to brute force you. It would be
really cool if we had a hashing function that has both really
good, like SHA-256, but also kind of slow. So that computers get
faster and faster, the hash function stays the same speed. And, I'm
about to tell you about such a function, it's called bcrypt. The
reason I didn't use it in my last example, is because it's
not built into Python. So it's not super convenient for me
to demonstrate. And I, and I don't want to have, you know,
expect you to install it. But you know in the future
outside this course, instead of SHA-56, use bcrypt instead. And your life
will be better. And what bcrypt, bcrypt is cool, it basically
takes an extra parameter, which is. How long do you want this
to take? and, and it's neat, so now you have this
function that will stay slow forever. Because you can make it slow.